foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday March 7th I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
Twitter has had a lot of layoffs since
Elon Musk took over in December he said
Twitter was down to roughly 2 000
employees it had close to 8 000 before
he acquired the company just a few
months earlier and since then we've
reported twitters made more cuts the
layoffs are part of cost cutting efforts
and their magnitude relative to
Twitter's size is unlike anything else
in Tech and that's got other Tech
leaders and investors curious how many
people does it take to run a tech
company joining us to discuss this is
our Twitter reporter Alexa course hi
Alexa thanks for coming back on tnb
thanks for having me so there have been
a lot of cuts at Twitter can you tell us
generally where are they coming from
within the company we don't have exact
numbers but we know layoffs have
affected teams across the company so the
big question with all of these Cuts is
how will they affect the running of the
platform the first thing is we have seen
some glitches can you tell us about
those and how Twitter has been reacting
to them of course Twitter is still
running so far it's not dead which might
seem surprising given all the layoffs
but we have seen several glitches in
recent weeks that's certainly raising
some questions last week for about two
hours there was an incident where users
said they were having trouble accessing
the timeline on Monday for about an hour
there were glitches with broken links
and images
and then Twitter said that they had
resolved that issue it's hard to tell
from the outside Twitter hasn't given
many details about what causes a
specific incident but we've certainly
seen these incidents in the last few
weeks so Alexa you've been speaking with
experts outside of Twitter what do they
think the impact of these layoffs is on
the company some experts I spoke to said
there's a difference between just trying
to keep a company running versus growing
really fast or when your site is growing
really fast then you're going to need
more people just to keep up but if
you're trying to maintain a system
that's already been built you might be
able to do that with a lot less people
okay well what about those people who
are still at the company have we heard
from them on how they feel since all
these layoffs started taking place yes
some employees who are still at Twitter
have said they really like some of the
changes some of the new features they've
called it more exciting now but I spoke
to some employees there who said they're
stretched really thin and scrambling
many Engineers have left and the
employees who are left are having to
jump in and work on these systems
they've never touched before sources
told me from the people you've spoken to
can you tell us you know what have their
experiences been like when they are
dealing with systems that they maybe
haven't had to deal with before as
Twitter employees well I heard this one
anecdote that I think illustrates some
of the confusion and frustration I was
hearing about two weeks ago Twitter
slack unexpectedly went down staff
couldn't get in and one of the employees
was telling me this was really
frustrating because slack was a way to
find old notes and helpful messages
especially when so many of your
colleagues have left the company me and
aren't there anymore to help so Twitter
said that slack is back now for staff
but that's one example of the
frustration I was hearing from some
employees still there you know a lot of
other tech companies are also announcing
layoffs and they're trying to do more
with less they're trying to be more
efficient what are they taking away from
Twitter's experience I've definitely
heard this from people in the industry
you know if Twitter can survive after
all these Cuts there's some people who
think that will inspire Executives some
Executives to try to be like Elon Musk
at least in some way try to be a little
more hardcore as musk has put it we've
seen layoffs across the tech industry
lately Google meta Salesforce Twitter's
cuts are of a different magnitude it's
not a perfect comparison but the whole
industry is watching what's happening
with Twitter right now and take you know
venture capitalist Gurley he was you
know tweeting about this in November and
his take is that you know he said
companies usually are too cautious when
they cut and they underestimate how
resilient companies are and so he
doesn't think that doomsday predictions
about Twitter are going to come through
and what about musk has he commented on
their ability to do more with less or
maybe do the same amount with less yeah
I mean musk has said he has like really
big Ambitions for Twitter Twitter has
been you know launching and tweaking new
features they revamped their
Subscription Service it's still early
days but in must view he said Twitter
had to do layoffs because they were
losing money and he now plans to turn it
around alright that's our Twitter
reporter Alexa course thanks for joining
us Alexa thanks for having me
alright that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]